à tous ceux qui sont restés jusqu'à
cette heure tardive je peux vous dire
conférence tedx ça se mérite j'espère
que vous n'êtes pas trop endormis parce
que j'avais l'intention de vous raconter
une histoire c'est peut-être pas la
meilleure heure toujours est il que je
suis ravi d'être ici et je savoure ma
chance est en fait j'avais préparé
quelque chose parce que jérémy vous avez
bien dit il faut répéter répéter
s'entraîner apprendre par coeur voilà
donc je pense qu'on avait tous bien
travaillé dans notre coin et moi comme à
chaque fois ça m'ennuie genre de truc
mais bon je l'avais fait quand même
parce que j'avais la chance de faire
tedx et puis je considère que c'est une
immense chance de terminer parce que
j'ai pu profiter pleinement de toutes
les conférences et de toutes les
rencontres que j'ai pu faire encore
aujourd'hui et j'ai juste été fasciné
tout au long de ce parcours parce qu'au
départ on s'était dit moi je me suis dit
devant la fiche bab on est on est
plusieurs on est nombreux et ça n'a pas
forcément de fil conducteur
et en écoutant toutes les conférences à
chaque fois ma conférence là et je passe
en dernier donc ce qui s'apparente à une
espèce de conclusion eh ben il y a un
petit bout de chacune des conférences
qui va être dans ce dont je vais vous
parler la première chose c'est ce
qu'elle dit
thaïs pour commencer moi je vais vous
raconter un peu mon histoire bien vite
fait parce que moi on s'en fout pourtant
c'est un des sujets que je maîtrise le
mieux
mais sa soeur si ça peut être possible
pourrait prendre des heures encore en
fait j'ai eu tout un parcours et j'ai
fait plein de choses et j'ai été
principalement alors pendant 15 ans rh
et managers dans un grand groupe
j'ai voyagé dans la france entière et
puis personnellement dans le monde
entier parce que j'ai un défaut selon
certaines personnes
j'aime les gens donc j'adore aller à la
rencontre des gens que je ne connais pas
et surtout ceux qui
je trouve bizarre en fait parce qu'on
m'a toujours dit que j'étais quelqu'un
de bizarre et donc j'ai fait ça et puis
le grand groupe avec toute cette
rentabilité cette question financière
c'est voilà ça mettait à chaque fois
selon moi pas l'humain au milieu des
préoccupations et moi c'était vraiment
toujours ma préoccupation
alors du coup pourtant on était très
très rentable finalement voilà et après
donc j'ai décidé d'arrêter le grand
groupe est de monter moi même une
société de services à la personne pour
lequel j'ai monté une équipe de 17
personnes encore hélas j'ai continué à
faire du management des ressources
humaines
j'ai rajouté le commercial financier
parce que quand on sa boîte faut tout
faire
voilà et puis après je me suis dit ouais
bon d'accord c'est sympa je me suis
rendu compte que ça devenait de plus en
plus difficiles et parce que les clients
devenait de plus en plus exigeants et
parce que le management devenait de plus
en plus compliqué donc je me suis posé
plein de questions puis entre temps le
drame est arrivé
j'ai eu des enfants hélas au secours ben
du coup tout est reparti à zéro c'était
plus possible je me suis posé un
milliard de questions et je me suis dit
balla va falloir faire quelque chose
donc j'ai comme j'avais commencé à
travailler avec des adultes
et puis du coup je me suis mis à
travailler avec les enfants parce que
toujours dans ma vie j'ai aussi les d'un
extrême à un autre alors extrême quand
même un peu modéré dans les extrêmes
mais j'aime bien pour trouver
l'équilibré aller d'un côté et de
l'autre pour trouver ce qui met qui
libre donc j'ai été travaillé avec les
petits enfants et j'ai été fasciné par
cette nouvelle génération qu'on peut
appeler x y z on
l'amélioration al fahm si jamais vous le
saviez pas donc je ne sais pas jusqu'où
on va aller mais en tout cas ça va très
très vite et il y avait toujours cette
angoisse au niveau des adultes qui
disait parce que nous on n'a pas ce
référentiel par rapport à tous ces
outils numériques que les enfants ont
maintenant et qui angoissait beaucoup
les parents donc du coup je me suis
après orienté sur les parents et puis je
me suis dit bon mais faut que je me
forme parce que rh et manager c'est
sympa mais ça suffit pas donc j'ai fait
une grosse formation en coaching
donc oui je sais c'est encore un gros
mot aujourd'hui mais c'est comme ça et
formatrice et puis avance en avançant
que je me suis spécialisé dans les ados
dans la systémie familiale parce que la
france aime bien les diplômés étiquette
mais là c'est bien propre et puis
j'avais appris que les jeunes allaient
été les décideurs de demain ça
paraissait super évident et puis moi je
suis aussi engagé en politique et
j'entendais toujours lé vieux c'est
l'avenir
ça m'angoisse est vachement et je me
disais par non alors oui financièrement
chp longtemps maintenant les décideurs
de demain ça reste quand même les
enfants
pardon parce que ça frottait ça fait du
bruit c'est insupportable
et ça reste pour moi les enfants est en
tout cas la jeune la jeunesse donc je me
suis spécialisé dans les ados et c'est
aujourd'hui ce projet que je porte
auprès d'eux donc je suis tous les jours
avec eux donc non je vais vous annoncer
quelque chose de très vrai ce ne sont
pas des abrutis bloqués sur leur
téléphone en mode bonobo comme ça non
pas du tout pas du tout en fait ce qu'il
faut savoir - souvent on en rigole de ça
c'est qu'on leur vend quand même et on a
pu avoir un petit échantillon
alors divorce orna dépression chômage
malbouffe perturbateur endocrinien
voilà c'est c'est assez angoissant
donc effectivement il ya plus de futurs
possibles en tout cas pas celui là et il
a vraiment le truc dans lequel j'ai
percuté c'est quand ma fille de quand
elle avait 11 ans m'a dit on sait quoi
maman moi je vais pas devenir adulte
parce que ça me fait pas rêver votre
truc
et donc je me suis dit faut vraiment
faire quelque chose alors j'ai réfléchi
parce que de tous constats puis alors
les parents étaient perdus parce qu'ils
savent plus vers qui se tourner on avait
effectivement des troubles du
comportement des 10 de tous les dans
tous les sens voilà donc à part donner
des médicaments à nos enfants je me suis
dit il y aurait peut-être un autre moyen
de faire les jeunes il n'avait pas de
sens plus de perspectives iap une
motivation n'a perdu la valeur travail
et moi je me suis rendu compte que tous
les jours je travaillais mais je ne
travaillais pas d'ailleurs il ya plein
de gens qui se disent haut et plutôt
assez facile tu travailles pas non c'est
vrai je ne travaille pas parce que je
m'éclate tous les jours donc j'ai pas
l'impression de travailler
est ce que j'ai envie aujourd'hui c'est
d'apporter de par mon projet donc un
endroit que je suis en train de créer
sur chambéry parce que oui je suis
chambérienne aussi où je vais créer un
lieu et j'ai beaucoup aimé cette bulle
d'humanité qu'on a pu vous en êtes
peut-être pas rendu compte là mais créer
cet après-midi en répétant tous ensemble
c'est à dire qu'on vient de plein de
milieux différents mais on est tous
pareils en fait alors on n'a pas eu le
temps de boire une bière tous tous
ensemble mais nous les huit ont la faire
et c'était vraiment fascinant j'ai
trouvé encore et encore de la magie dans
ses rapports humains de l'harmonie dans
ce qui s'est créé tout au long de toutes
ces conférences qui se sont déroulés et
c'est ça que j'ai envie d'offrir
aujourd'hui de remettre la valeur
travail mais a lié à la passion au
plaisir et de faire comprendre aux
jeunes qu'on peut oui faire de sa
passion un métier faut bosser il ya des
mois
et puis il ya d'autres métiers parce
qu'on sait aujourd'hui que l'âge
nouvelle génération va créer 60 % des
nouveaux métiers donc on parlait de la
fin de certains métiers oui c'est vrai
mais en fait c'est eux qui vont créer
les nouveaux alors moi je vous ai dit
que j'étais coach et formatrice
ça c'est le truc parce que c'est ce
qu'on peut mettre sur sa plaque et
j'hésite encore parce que je viens de
créer mon métier moi je suis créatrice
dans vie est révélatrice de pépites et
c'est ça aujourd'hui que j'ai envie
goulette sur ma plaque jean luminet sur
ma carte c'est encore un peu compliqué
parce que hein mon assureur a déjà du
mal à assurer le coaching alors
révélatrice de pépi qui va me dire d'un
maître d'art est parce que là je vois là
c'est super compliqué pour rentrer dans
les cases l'insee et puis quand on se
déclare alors là ça c'est autre à petit
bois là et est donc ce lieu que j'ai
j'ai donc m'est venue après tout ce
constat des parents des professionnels
sur le terrain qui sont usés qui ont plu
duty il faut savoir que moi je fais pas
mal de conférence est et j'ai toujours
des photos lors la juge je vous les
épargner mais je prends une photo d'un
d'une voiture de 1920 et d'une bonne
grosse ferrari d'aujourd'hui on principe
on voit bien la différence
après je prends le vieux téléphone créé
par bell vraiment le truc qu'on était
comme ça et le l'iphone 8 qui est pas
encore sorti mais voilà dix publient et
une salle de classe des années trente et
une salle de classe d'aujourd'hui c'est
le seul truc qui n'a pas bougé il ya un
prof au tableau et une petite masse
d'élèves qui est posée là en rang
d'oignon et derrière son bureau
et ça c'est un vrai problème aujourd'hui
est souvent on m'a dit oui mais toi tu
es une licorne en plus des amis c'était
plus ou nounours et puis en plus tu
manges des paillettes au petit déjeuner
donc oui c'est vrai j'avoue d'ailleurs
j'ai pas osé faire comme marion un
minimum
les cornes parce que je pensais qu'elle
salir et un peu plus que le vélo oui
mais j'ai quand même vachement les pieds
sur terre parce que déjà j'ai géré du
personnel pendant plus de vingt ans j'ai
eu des entreprises qui ont très bien
fonctionné
aujourd'hui je peux être fier d'avoir
des fiches de paie de l'éducation
nationale estampillé coach parce que je
suis rentrée dans les lycées et les
collèges pour apporter un soutien aux
jeunes et un soutien aux profs et
maintenant je me déplace aussi dans les
structures donc mon lieu va être une un
lieu d'accueil d'écouté un lieu
ressource un lieu relais pour pouvoir
accueillir les jeunes les parents les
professionnels tous ceux qui voudront
venir on va avoir toute une grosse
partie artistique parce que parce que
j'adore l'art et je trouve que faire de
notre vie une oeuvre d'art c'est juste
ce qui peut nous porter aussi et tous
ensemble comme ça dans cette espèce de
moi je fais on dit des fois que tu peux
je fais du social je crois pas faire du
social je crois que je fais du sociétal
et pour moi c'est important de prendre
tout le monde en content d'être là tous
ensemble ça circule ça va ça vient
l'intelligence collective on partage on
échange et on construit l'avenir de
demain qui est le leur qui est le nôtre
et celui de l'humanité
alors même si c'est un petit peu
compliquer aujourd'hui je pense que
c'est ensemble qu'on va trouver les
solutions moi j'ai été nourri à
l'histoire du colibri donc juste avant
de vous endormir je vais vous la
raconter c'est l'histoire du colibri
donc certains d'entre vous doivent la
connaître si ce n'est toute l'assemblée
parce qu'elle est quand même
relativement connu dans cette forêt qui
prend feu
c'est une catastrophe tout est en feu et
tous les animaux s'échappe alléger les
folles ces propos tam les
les lions les tigres tous les plus gros
animaux s'échapper puis à le petit
colibri qui fait des allers-retours je
sais pas si vous avez déjà vu un colibri
c'est un mec absolument minuscule et
donc qui jette une goutte d'eau il fait
des allers retours y jette une goutte
d'eau et à un moment donné les singes
complètement paniqué lui dise arrête
arrête fui parce que c'est en train de
brûler et lui et répond simplement je
fais ma part moi c'est ce que j'ai envie
de faire aujourd'hui c'est faire ma part
à mon petit niveau à mon niveau local
mais tous ensemble en rencontrant des
gens tous les jours je ne fais que ça
tous les jours et c'est ça mon travail
de rencontrer des gens donc oui j'ai
l'impression je ne travaille pas juste
je me fais plaisir tous les jours et je
vous remercie
[Applaudissements]